[Musique]
attention aux patrons notre nuage arrive
de plus en plus près des étoiles
lutteront nounours ce ne sont pas des
étoiles ce sont les lumières de la ville
regarde mais oui tu peux
nous sommes arrivés chez nicolas et
pimprenelle je descends leur apprendre à
regarder au loin avec des jumelles
europe pape appelle popotin
bonsoir nicolas brault soir imprenable
[Musique]
bonjour doucement
oui mais faites attention elles sont
fragiles j'y tiens bon
[Musique]
ce
n'est pas fait pour regarder de cyprès
les jumelles il faut s'en servir pour
voir au loin
pour voir les étoiles les bretagne les
courses de chevaux
oui tu vas voir une course de chevaux
[Musique]
allez
ne veut pas trash pâle mois
jaloux
[Musique]
je
vous avais pas pousser les cheveux il
faut leur donner les bases de la foi toi
vous commencez à gérer je ne veux pas
jouer australe
je ne suis pas ta dans oi
une bande de gars tu es agro mignon
petit
[Musique]
nom je suis très fâché rendez moi ma
jumelle je voudrais
au
garnement or je ne viendrai plus vous
voir vous êtes trop
méchant
a
[Musique]
lieu
alors nounours était belge humaine on
sait pas trop comment ils colorent et
pimprenelle sont d'horribles petit
diable c'est fini je n'irai plus jamais
les voir ils m'ont humilié
vous vous rendez compte ils m'ont traité
comme un an
le vilain olemps console toi ce sont des
enfants ils sont méchants aujourd'hui
mais demain ils seront très gentil vous
croyez j'en suis certain jo les hommes
seul mot est aussi le thème le ch leurs
petits en route patron bonne et des
enfants faute de boer
à
[Musique]
oh